southwest valley high school taking
extra steps to keep its students safe at
home sporting events this comes after a
fight broke out led to gunfire in the
parking lot after a football game last
week sasha loftus joins us live at
desert oasis high right near buffalo and
cactus with more on this
brian families are starting to file in
ahead of kickoff here at desert oasis in
just under 30 minutes new safety
measures are in place after you
mentioned a fight broke out after last
week's game and led to gunfire
a letter sent to parents said no
backpacks or bags are allowed for the
game tonight students attending must get
their tickets ahead of time online and
present their school id when they arrive
they also need to have a parent come
with them anyone coming to watch the
visiting team must also show a school id
at the door
now again this game starts at 5 30
according to that letter sent to parents
all home games will now start at the
same time 5 30 p.m we are working to
speak with families to get their
reaction to this we'll have more tonight
at 6 and 11 o'clock on 8 news now
reporting live sasha loftis 8 news now